KYLE KEANE: All right.
Cool.
So projects, presentations
are going to happen.
And we're going to start
with the video games,
and then we're going to take
a cool break in the middle
to play with a collaborative,
crowdsourced, cloud-based robot
that's going to try to follow
all of our collective input
in order to grab
a piece of paper,
that Abhinav, the TA
for the Arduino class,
has been building
in his free time.
That's a good embarrassed face.
So that's a way to
model embarrassment.
I appreciate that, because we're
all going to feel embarrassed
when we present, and that's OK.
I feel embarrassed right now
trying to get your attention
and pull you away
from your projects,
because I know that that's what
you want to be doing right now.
So that's OK.
We're all going to
feel embarrassed.
But we're going to
share, and not in order
to impress everyone with
how amazing our project was,
but to open up a dialogue
about what we learned
and what other people
can learn from us.
So the point of coming up
and sharing your presentation
is not to get accolades
from your friends
about how amazingly
brilliant you are.
It's to share something, so
that if someone's interest gets
piqued, they can go, oh, cool!
How did you do that thing?
And then you have a
chance to teach them
about that really
specific thing that you
did, if you were able to make a
really cute thing on the screen
move, or if you're able to make
a really cool video game work,
or if you're able to make a fun
Arduino electronics project.
This is your chance to
teach by sharing what you do
and inviting other people
to ask questions about it.
So this is not about
impressing each other.
Most of you will never--
which way are you
trying to shift me?
Oh, yeah.
You guys.
Most of you won't
talk after this class,
so don't worry if you do
something embarrassing.
You won't see most
of these people.
The ones that you do,
exchange emails with them
and talk to them
after, and they're not
going to care if you do
something silly up here.
So I just want to
set the expectation
that this is not a competitive
presentation environment.
We're not getting
venture capital.
There's nothing other than
a learning opportunity here.
ANDREW RINGLER: As Kyle
said, we're not competing.
Hopefully you had fun
and learned something
over the last two weeks.
That's teachers'
only goal, to let you
have fun and learn something.
So yeah.
I think the point
of this two weeks
is to get your feet
wet with Arduino
and see what it's like to plan
a project and try to build it,
and then figure out how
to do it better next time.
So that's what we do.
But that said, all your
groups did amazing.
You did so much work,
which is awesome,
and we're all excited to see
what you have to present.
Thank you.
All right.
KYLE KEANE: You're done?
ANDREW RINGLER: Yes, I'm done.
KYLE KEANE: All right, cool.
ANDREW RINGLER: Come on in.
KYLE KEANE: All right.
So the first group to
present is going to--
I'll let them come
up and introduce.
So the video game
groups, when you
come up, take the microphone,
introduce your game,
demo your game--
or introduce your game,
talk about anything
that you feel inspired to
talk about, if there is a fun,
interesting learning experience,
or if something gets you really
excited, talk about that.
Demo your game.
And then we're going to
open it up to questions.
As an audience
member, the best thing
that you can do to support
someone who's presenting
is to make occasional eye
contact and pay some attention,
and then at the end be able to
ask a question that reflects--
I know.
I'm very explicit,
but you'd be amazed
at how many people
don't make eye
contact with the presenters.
And then ask
questions at the end,
which reflects something like--
that looked really cool.
How did you do that?
And what you're doing is
you're setting them up
to look smart and share
something that they're
passionate about
and feel supported.
And you, too, will have
your chance to be up here.
And I guarantee
that you will want
to have an audience
that makes eye contact
and then asks you
questions about things that
were interesting in your project
so that you, too, can feel
supported and interesting
and like people
care about what you're doing.
Because a lot of this class was
two weeks of passion projects.
We don't have a
lot of structure,
because I think that
you're here for two weeks,
and you should opt into the
project that you want to do,
and you should find people
that you want to work with.
So a lot of this
work that you've
done over the last
two weeks represents
a personal investment.
And so respect
that in each other.
Everyone who's up
here presenting
put a lot of their own
interest and passion into this.
So yeah-- support,
support, support.
So, first group, are
you ready to present?
All right.
Here you go.
[CLAPPING]